Hi everybody. I'm Ysef Urban and I will
say uh something actually it's this
paper that I put on archive
in uh January
and I should warn you that a lot of this
work has been done by chat GPT including
the slides uh but when I I went over the
slides so there there should shouldn't
be some uh major um misinformation
there. And uh another thing that the AI
has produced is a podcast like a
15-minute podcast which I put on
YouTube. So there is some misinformation
there but it's much better in propaganda
than I am. So so if you if you want to
hype it up then listen to the podcast.
So so this is the executive summary. So
I took a relatively well-known book on
topology which has a major part on
general topology
and try to auto formalize it and I took
uh like uh CH GPT 5.2 2 mostly uh and
um the kind of coding agent uh that
these companies and also some open
source people are these days developing
which are mostly uh developed to to do
autonomously uh coding for for you like
like some software development and I
kind kind of very simply hooked it up to
to a proof checker
and told it just like here is here is
the textbook here is the latte uh which
is like I think like 250
pages of general topology please try to
auto formalize it so so that it proof
proof checks um and the the the result
was quite interesting so the first
weekend when it started to happen I
almost didn't sleep because I I was
really a bit hypnotized by how how it
was working and I also needed to
interact with it. But ultimately like by
the time I put the paper on the archive,
it produced
150,000 lines of uh relatively like like
proof checked formalized topology with
some major
uh theorems in it of which
130,000s were produced basically in 2
weeks when I decided to pay the kind of
heaviest usage subscription.
uh to open AAI uh the I I have just
today looked at how it progressed. So
that's this BCK 516
uh backup and I I I guess the
outcome of of that uh which I will
mention later is that what the the the
process kind of didn't stop. it it kind
of continues growing quite uh quite
quickly and I I should say like one of
the surprising thing like in the podcast
AI generated they they call me a garage
hacker uh so uh the the the kind of
funny aspect of it is basically
everybody can do it today like there's
really nothing extraordinary that I I
have done uh so so that's kind of an
interesting message that uh maybe we
will really get out of formalization
done
uh in 2026
uh without some serious effort or
science.
Uh so so this slide is a bit about like
this topology that I decided to
formalize
and uh I don't know what exactly was the
reason like we were also with Chad Brown
uh we were setting the experiment up and
I was telling him that we could do angle
king and he said no I studied monkress
so we took monkress maybe one reason why
we took topology
was that Chad has his uh pet proof
assistant called Megalodon which is the
successor of his egal proof assistant
which is his like a high order set
theory with khawart proof terms I guess
it to some extent resembles but
it's I would say much more bare bones
much more lowlevel much more declarative
and
uh also yeah like like uh more limited I
would say in in various ways. So Chad
has used his brief assistant to
formalize um a lot of set theory in
particular he developed uh the serial
numbers that convey convey numbers. So
topology was like a reasonable thing to
try when when you already have like
enough uh enough uh set theory. Uh
uh yeah and yeah we should say that the
target of this is not some theorem
proving or automated theorem proving.
The target is is more like u here is
here is the book read the latte proof
and try to express what's written in
natural language in the formal language
of of this uh proof checker. So in in
principle we shouldn't be doing too much
uh fancy automated theorem proving but
obviously these things sometimes
interfere in various ways. Okay. So, so
this is the high level loop as I already
said like like we have the LLM and the
kind of coding agent which is like a
reper around the LLM and we let the
coding agent talk to to this kind of
compiler or proof checker which behaves
as a compiler in this case Megalodone.
And the the good thing about Megalodon,
even though it's kind of so bare bones,
it has a reasonable error messaging. So
So it you can run it relatively quickly.
It runs quite fast and it reports quite
reasonably like there is an error on
line 156 and the error seems to be that
and it seems to be good enough for these
today's like general LLMs to
to iterate to so so so the LLM gets it
wrong uh very often like very much but
it seems to have the capability to to
kind of look at the error message look
at the line when it did something wrong
and try try to fix uh the error like
sometimes this really takes a while uh
like I should say the megalodon is like
a virtually unknown proof assistant
which doesn't have a high presence on
GitHub or internet. So it's quite clear
that the LLMs aren't much trained on the
Megalodon code,
but still like like surprisingly
like the the language that Megalodon is
using isn't something super fancy,
something super unfamiliar. So, so the
LLM learns the syntax relatively
reasonably
and it also kind of learns how to do the
proofs even though it's kind of doing
doing mistakes all the time. But like
this quick error messaging is is a very
good way how to always remind it don't
do this, do do that. and it seems to be
working like it could probably work
better if you trained more on this
particular uh proof style but it already
works uh well well enough uh so when I
saw and chat kind of confirmed that that
it's uh doing reasonable stuff like the
the I don't know definition of topology
that created and the first theorems that
created looked okay to me and uh to to
chat. Then I I basically let it run. So
So at that point it has this relatively
big uh file with uh the topology
development and obviously I I told it
something like okay you you you need to
formalize this all. So you should try to
formalize the statements the definitions
um and then gradually do the proofs. You
don't have to finish the proofs
immediately. uh you should kind of do
things gradually in various ways but
occasionally try to finish uh some
stuff. So so it kind of uh did its own
thinking how how to basically schedule
this this uh ver which is also quite uh
interesting. Uh yeah I guess I have
already uh explained all of this. So,
so, so an important part in like this uh
megalodon prover is that it's like also
like relatively declarative like like
the proofs. So you can
um most of the time see very clearly
what you are proving like like the proof
style allows the LLM to to see yeah now
now now I'm in this part of the proof I
can use these assumptions or previously
proof lemas and now I need to prove this
next small lema and everything is kind
of very clear. So I I think that's
that's very useful for the LOM
and you can as I said you can do things
gradually using this admit keyword which
I think comes from uh coke. So, so I
think I kind of explicitly instructed it
to to proceed in this way to to kind of
start with these like misar style proof
sketches um and then gradually
make them more and more
uh deep and uh developed until basically
that there is no admit uh anywhere in in
the tooth.
Uh yeah and this slide also says that I
kind of did a bit of sandboxing.
So so these coding agents are in um
theory pretty dangerous objects like if
you gave them like a full power over
your computer they could probably do
things that you do not want them to do.
So I just use this bubbler app which
seems to be like a reasonable tool. how
to isolate some working environment
inside uh my my Linux notebook or my
Linux uh server and like gradually I've
moved the work to a server where I'm
running the the auto formalization
session in something like a GNU screen
and this T-Max the terminal multiplexer
and I'm kind of backing it up and
pushing it to to GitHub.
Uh why megalodon? So I should say by now
we have tried it with at least three
other systems with whole light uh with
Agda
uh with Napro and uh Zaril has been
doing a lot of experiments with Lena. So
I I don't know how much Megalodon
actually matters. the the the the thing
here is that like I'm I'm using like
this compilation fast checking uh mode
which is just kind of good for my
laziness.
So I can imagine and I think John
Harrison and Jun Lean are now working on
that you can set up something which
works in the kind of interactive mode
like when you are for example in the
okamel readal print loop and you are
continuously issuing the commands and
okamel is responding to you. But I I was
kind of too cautious and too lazy. I was
thinking what if the coding agent
uh invokes some exception and the the
whole thing will have to be watched much
more than I'm watching it. So, so I I
preferred like this kind of misar style
compilation style, but I think it's not
really a big deal to to set things up
also in in this kind of interactive uh
mode which for example whole light is is
using. Uh, one thing I'm doing which I
may be able to show you is that I am
basically HTML
development
kind of as soon as I push it on GitHub
which allows me to click through these
proofs and see what went wrong or how
the proofs were uh done.
Uh, oh yeah. So, so I don't know the the
uh CH GBD called this the one prompt
trick. So, so at some point I paid for
for this big uh CH GPD Pro subscription
uh and uh I needed to automate things
because suddenly I had a lot of credits
for using the LLM and it wasn't before
that it was waiting all the time for the
kind of credits
uh to reset but like when I paid the
$200
per month's subscription. It's it was
running kind of continuously. So I did
this hack which is I'm running it in
this terminal multiplexer in this T-max
and whenever the coding agent kind of
comes back to me and says I have
finished the work uh give me some more
work I detect it from the outside and I
automatically inject this prompt which
says read the file called MD treat it as
authoritative work instruction and work
as long as possible.
And so so this is I don't know like two
three sentences and most of the prompt
or rules is in this relatively big file
called cloth MD which is fully printed
in the archive paper which tells tells
it what to do and what not to do. So, so
it for example tells it only to edit in
the topology section, never edit in the
set theory section that child has
already uh formalized.
Don't throw away a work that you have
already done. Try to always add more
work. uh some some kind of very simple
warnings about the language because
sometimes it can get stuck by I don't
know assuming that you can do some
comments and it actually cannot do those
comments and then it could take a while
to to recover
and I also eventually added some kind of
dependency tracking and progress
monitoring because the development
became big and Um I felt like the the uh
LLM needs kind of some tools to to
better orient itself like what depends
on what and which sections of the book
are covered and which still need to be
covered etc.
Uh
so
yeah as I said I I have this kind of
prompt uh injection
which is like like this kind of poor
man's interactive agent uh basically and
it works so so just just by doing like
this very primitive automation I
basically
made it work autonomously for for a
month like without me doing any any
babysitting like the only reason why it
stops at some point is that I run out of
the usage quotas by CH GPT. So that is
now happening uh like after 3 or 4 days
of continuous running uh open AAI tells
me that either I need to wait or I
should pay them more money. So I
typically wait and sometimes the the
model the coding agent has some
limitations.
So it kind of runs out. So so it has
this magical
thing called context compat
compactification. So, so it's kind of
keeping the history of of the
interaction and
uh because its context window is huge
but still limited at at some point it
needs to decide what to throw out of the
context window. So that process seems to
be some proprietary fancy technology uh
which decides which part of the
conversation very important and which
can be forgotten and uh usually it kind
of works but uh especially this chpt
it uh sometimes declares itself to be
like totally
um nonfixable. model and I have to do
what the podcast called lobotomy on the
on the language model. So, so, so my
solution is that I I basically revert to
a early
uh much earlier version of the
conversation
which is much smaller and I know that
that conversation was continued for I
don't know maybe five more days and I
just tell tell that younger version uh
here is the very
older version that uh try to catch up
with your older version and continue
from where your older version uh
stopped.
Uh so yeah so so in the paper I'm
reporting the these numbers. So 160
lines in total and 130 uh,000 lines uh
in in these two weeks and about 1.5,000
lemasan theorems.
uh what I saw today in this latest
backup is about 250,000 lines uh about
11 megabytes
and 2,217
stated uh theorems and lamas of which
2,124
are proved without recursive admits. So,
so this the dependency tracking script
which I have is kind of uh recording the
extracting the information like what uh
what was proved with an admit and what
was proved with without an admit but
with a dependency which is admitted. So,
so that's the current numbers.
Uh,
and uh, yeah.
Yeah. This is I guess what I just uh
said.
So, so you you want to obviously in the
beginning where then it just sketched
only the statements everything is
admitted and and the process of
formalization is kind of moving
uh the admitted theorems into the fully
fully proved uh theorems.
Uh so people like I'm Nant here who are
linguists and have been in this business
for a while have asked me how how
does it recover from mistakes. So so I
you you can look at the 5,000 com
commits if you want but but here is one
email that I sent to Ara like some time
ago. So uh for example here
uh that there was a missing assumption
that a family that that Capital C is a
family of subsets of of the topological
space of of the carrier of the
topological space and uh the this was
how the initial auto out ofization did
it. So, so the initial out ofization did
quite a lot of simplifications,
mistakes, stops,
etc. But then it kind of it is
instructed to to prove prove the
theorems and uh during the proof
checking it it suddenly sees that
something isn't right. So, so then it
quite often kind of goes back to the
latte uh file and it looks at how it was
initially auto formalized and it sees oh
here is a missing condition. I I should
add an uh assumption to to the statement
of the theorem. So, so what it's quite
interesting in in the sense that if you
were doing some kind of oneshot auto
formalization of a single statement, it
it kind of is quite likely to do these
mistakes. But if you are autofirmalizing
a whole book, the the whole book
probably works as some kind of internal
consistency checker like you uh like I
think the language model doesn't want to
cheat
uh consciously but but it's making
mistakes and basically when it's
instructed to to finish the proofs it
will it will try to fix things if if if
it uh can
uh yeah so so for example here's the
continuation of the email that I sent to
Ara so there is still or at least when I
was checking this like 10 days ago the
definition of local uh finitness
uh in latte says that f is a family of
subsets of x but the formal definition
doesn't require that So the the the
current thing is kind of always adding
this assumption to the various u
theorems where where this is being used
but uh like what I told Arnet that like
if the LLM sees like enough of this
friction then it's quite likely that the
the definition will eventually get fixed
that the that the LLM will decide Okay,
I I have been I have been doing this
wrong and I should probably um modify
this definition.
Uh this is some statistics that I tried
to do yesterday. It may be imprecise. So
the original latte is about 176 proofed
uh major statements like the samas and
corollaries
and then there is 115 examples and uh
207 exercises and the exercises have no
proof. So so that's quite interesting.
So in total you have like 500 things
that you can prove in in this book.
uh but um unfortunately
uh uh 40% of the stuff that doesn't have
a proof like the desire exercises. So,
so initially when I saw what the LLM was
doing, I I saw that it's getting into
proving the exercises quite quite a bit.
But um I kind of didn't want it well for
couple of reasons like one reason is
that this like it should formalize the
major topological theorems. It shouldn't
be formalizing some exercises nobody
knows about. But but also like doing the
exercises is kind of a creative process
or I don't know the LLM has seen all of
the internet so and it has stolen all
all of the books out there. So so the
LLM probably has seen the solutions of a
lot of these exercises somewhere on the
internet but still like it's it's not
out of formalization to to to give a
proof for for an exercise which isn't
written in in the book. So I kind of
modified the rules to tell it that it
should prioritize like the theorems, the
major theorems and uh don't focus too
too much on the exercises and the and
the examples. I also looked yesterday at
like how many of of these 176
major things can be kind of found uh
semi-automatically in the formalization
and with some initial hacking I found
110 to 120 of those but like I I I can
imagine that with more detective work I
could do more
uh boot I'm
um yeah so as I said like later I have
added like this dependency tracking
because this like 2,00 lemas it looked
like it's it's getting uh trouble
detecting
what remains to be proved to to finish
some major uh theorem. So, so I I think
like this very simple dependency
tracking tool which I added uh helped it
with with that kind of stuff
and um then like towards the end of the
year I I saw that it really got uh
seriously into proving some of these
major theorems like horizont.
So I I did some kind of targeted
prompting but not like a major
targeting. I basically just told it try
to finish the proof of horizont
and it kind of helped. So it uh it kind
of focused on the horizontal. What what
what I tell it in the rules file is to
be not to be super focused on just one
thing but try to cover the whole thing
because if you only focus on one part
you might miss some dependencies between
the sections and then later you might
have to refactor the stuff too much. So,
so I wanted it to kind of have some
initial coverage of everything but then
you also wanted to to really prove uh
some non-trivial stuff. So, so there
there is this tension and in in this
case like just telling it well try to
observe the rules but then also try to
prove some serious theorems like for
example lema seem to have uh worked for
I don't know if I have the ta
yeah uh let me say something about ta so
so ta was was this humongous 10,000
lines proof which it finished on January
Or and the interesting thing is that
there is a forward um dependence in in
the proof like the proof needs u
complete uh uniform convergence on
complete matrix spaces which is uh in
section 43 but the proof of theta is I
think section 35 or something like that
and it really uh made the LLM quite
uncertain. So, so it it it was in this
kind of schizophrenic mode trying to use
the stuff that it that I told it like
like you you cannot use forward
references. So, so it produced like
6,000 lines of just expanding the
inductive proof into more and more terms
but not not doing the induction. But
then the interesting thing was that it
kind of eventually saw that this is
going nowhere and it kind of refactored
the the book in a in a way. It kind of
moved some parts from the section uh 43
before the section 35 which allowed it
to to finish the proof of TA. So the the
proof of data type is probably highly
redundant but anyway it compiles them.
Uh yeah so here I wanted to mention that
some of these things we did recently
also in whole light with John Harrison
and Juni his his colleague at Amazon. So
so John has been formalizing a lot of
topology. So we had already the
horizontal but not the materization
and we set it up very similarly just
this whole light and cloth uh code
instead of the CH GPD pro codecs and it
took a bit more than one day I had some
debugging to to do there but John
basically confirmed that it's it's good
so we had the first success and then
it Uh it also did the stones uh figure
like this week basically which was
another uh challenge uh from John. Uh it
kind of allowed me to compare like this
tactical proof style used in whole light
with the declarative proof style used in
Megalodon. And initially I wasn't even
sure that it would prove the thing in
whole light because I was kind of
running it in this compilation mode. But
it's it's kind of very hard to read the
proof scripts that you produce in whole
light. It's it's just a chain chaining
of tactics and you don't see the current
goals uh when you are writing the whole
script. So I had to give it some
debugging uh code to so that it can see
the current goal when it when it fails.
But but so so initially I I was already
quite pessimistic that the whole light
might not be a good system for doing
this as at least not the way I I was
doing it but then it started to get
better and better and now it seems like
it it can do things also quite
reasonably in in whole light.
Uh
yeah, I'll probably skip skip this. I
already mentioned it. Yeah, I also
mentioned Ter.
Uh yeah, like I mentioned the sandboxing
already
compactification. Yeah. Yeah. So I also
spoke about it. Yeah. So So yeah, I have
this headline that you can do it for 100
bucks. So I should say that there is
uh this is kind of true but but I I've
seen a bit of the credit degradation.
So it did quite a lot initially for this
100 bucks for the two weeks. Uh but in
in the month it uh became a bit less but
but it's still pretty pretty impressive.
Uh oh yeah this is the podcast if you
listen to it. So so they are calling
meon the bouncer who is watching the llm
not to hallucinate.
Yeah. So research questions.
Yeah. How much is it checker dependent
versus the the kind of loomed loop that
we have. I don't know. I'm I'm kind of
now thinking that it might not be super
checker dependent. What seems to be
relatively important is the error
messaging and and being able to see the
goal and and the basically proof state
uh shrinking and refactoring. So it is
doing quite some refactoring in the in
the melodon experiment. I think it could
be prompted to do even more refactoring
and maybe I could give it some more
tools which will I don't know do some
anti-ionification for example and try to
pull out the general leas uh but I
haven't done that yet.
Then there are hammers. So so in whole
light you do have the mazon tactic and
things like that. So you can say that it
already has the hammer in whole light.
In Megalodon, I tried to use a hammer,
but it doesn't have the reconstruction,
the proof reconstruction. So, so it kind
of didn't work uh too much.
Uh yeah, can the agent learn it to
reorder the textbook? Uh it kind of
struggles, but but it seems to be
capable of doing it occasionally at
least. Uh yeah, quality insurance. Yeah,
you ask John Harrison or Chad Brown
whether it's doing what what it's
supposed to be doing. Yeah, I wanted to
mention Zar Gertzel who kind of
motivated me to do this. So Zar has now
uh auto formalized this big paper about
Kevin and Skillink about foundations of
inference.
So he did it in lean and you can ask him
about it. I I I think it's it's kind of
a similar approach like the coding agent
which uh which I'm using and it's it's
quite an interesting work. So we will he
has a write up about it. It for example
found some work from 1950s which is
usable to fill in some gaps in in in the
proofs there.
Uh yeah, so these are the co-workers and
acknowledgements
and uh yeah, what else should I say
here? Uh
um
yeah. Well, for for me this is quite
surprising like like I I kind of started
to propose auto formalization in 2013 14
because like these tools like Google
translate were getting quite good. But
like what you can today do with these
agents which have like this body of
general knowledge like they can reason
not just about the proofs but also how
to refactor the book for example is is
quite uh surprising to me. So, so it
could really, as I said in the
beginning, it could really be that in
we will basically start formalizing by
LLMs and forget that it was hard work
for humans. Okay, that that's it. And I
can show you some demos if you want.
So I I had so I should first maybe I
made it clear I'm I'm neither a
megalodon person nor a whole light
person. I kind of superficially know
these systems. Uh but I what got me
going in the beginning when I told it
could you auto formalize
the the initial definitions was that
Chad Brown was standing next to me and
it wrote the definition of topological
space and Chad was like holy crap like
what is this? This is how I would have
written the definition myself. So, so
Chad Chad was really like he he's like a
non non AI person and he he was quite
surprised how how it was written in the
way that he he would have written it. So
So and and then kind of Chad kind of
kept confirming uh occasionally that
it's it's doing things reasonably. The
the other feedback I got from John
Harrison when it in the last and this
week auto formalized like this
materization and stone stuff like John
John said that that it looks good. So
like John is the master of verbalization
so I trust him. Uh
yeah. Uh so on the other hand like I you
you have seen for example this email
that I have sent to Amaranta where I'm
commenting on on the wrong way how it
initially how to formalize something and
then it's kind of trying to recover uh
from that. So I I will say that this is
some kind of interesting process which
can probably be improved in various ways
both by better prompting and by giving
in some better tools like various style
checking tools etc. Uh and yeah that's
that's all I know at this point. that
there.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And actually June Lee has already
done it for a whole life. That's like a
very recent development. June and John
have kind of seen the the struggle that
I I was getting with with doing it in
this kind of brute force stupid way and
and they uh kind of did just what you
are saying. I I just haven't tried it
yet.
Yeah.
Mhm. Mhm.
Yeah. So, so actually I I had a postoc
for two years uh Jonathan Werta in Muna
who who was working on connecting
language models to to Isabel and doing
reinforcement. So so he is coming to
visit us um I don't know a month from
now and he he was talking with Macarios
about this kind of stuff. So I I hope I
hope he will provide the expertise to to
to do these things.
So it's it's really very interesting how
how the LLMs or the coding agents are
coping or not coping with with the gaps
like with these forward references in in
the proof of TA. It's uh it's it's kind
of a you I like when I was thinking
about autobalization 10 years ago, I was
thinking about it as a translation task
like like English to French. But but
it's when you encounter a gap like this,
you you realize that this is much more
than that, right? Like like
and it's really interesting what the
LLMs can do and what they cannot cannot
do. Yeah.
Defense
he can hear you. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
So again like there is too too much
stuff to to go through but I can tell
you some first impressions. So yes, like
at at some point, so for example, where
it it it has occasionally really done
strange things. So last week when we
were doing John's thing it like the
first 4 hours of formalizing this whole
light uh thing was clo code adding the
library to to the current file with with
the proofs basically copy pasting them
and congratulating
congratulating itself for doing
substantial substantial work. So, so I
needed to change the prompt the rules
file and tell it you really really
shouldn't duplicate what already exists.
So, so that's one way how how it can go
off the rails like do doing some kind of
easy copy pasting instead of focusing on
on the problem. But like in this
megalodon thing, what happened to me
quite early was that I don't know where
where it saw maybe somewhere on the
internet. it it had let's say like these
hard theorems that it was supposed to be
proving and it started to introduce an
aum for each of them which looked
basically the same and it was getting
the theorem proved by by by having the
ex so so again I I needed to modify the
rules book telling it well don't add
exoms uh so it's it's it's doing quite
this weird stuff every now and Um yeah.
Yeah.
So I'm afraid this is something that you
would have to do yourself or ask
somebody who has tried. I I basically
lost the capability to train these big
models I don't know like some five six
years ago. Uh so I'm I'm only training
small small models. I like in in this
like let's say you you can say that
there is a lot of whole light whole for
code out there on the internet but for
megalodon it's kind of hard to argue
that there there is a lot of megal
megalodon formalization on the internet
yet it kind of with enough area
messaging it it kind of finds it uh way
through so I would say there definitely
is some amount of in context uh learning
go going on in in these very big
language models which allow it to to
kind of understand a new language which
is not too dissimilar from from the
existing uh languages I could imagine
and it's occasionally frustrating that
if I kind of had the capacity to to
train it myself and I would train it on
megalodon proofs it stop doing the the
most common mistakes that that that it's
uh currently
uh doing. Uh what what is slightly
interesting but that's probably all just
proprietary technology is that it seems
like both especially I will say in the
whole light case it seems to have
struggled initially quite a lot and then
it became better and better. So, so I
would assume
that it's kind of getting this very long
session and it's doing a lot of in
context uh learning on on the very very
big session. But yeah, like there are
these compactification phases which are
probably totally proprietary and nobody
knows what's going on there. So, so my
advice is yeah, do the research like
there is a lot of interesting research
to to be done there.
So to to be honest, I I know very little
so far how how these coding agents are
implemented. I I just tried it and it
seems to be doing something. And um I I
I think uh people are working on open
source coding agents. So we were already
discussing it I think with the Napro
guys like Atla Adrian and also with Zar
and Yaenbrook
that we could really look at uh some I
think there is like Quen code which is
an open source coding agent uh running
on top of Quen or Deepseek or whatever
and I guess there you could you could
start doing the modification that you
are uh proposing like uh I have no idea
at this point how how these things are
developed. Uh what I would now now that
I'm me mentioning these open source
coding agents what what seems to be
interesting and like Zel and also John
Harrison confirmed it is that what it it
seems like a good idea to use for
example DeepS which is open source and
do some finetuning etc etc but um there
is really a performance jump between CH
GPT 5.1 and CH GPT 5.2 and also between
CL set and cloth OPUS. So, uh it's it it
seems like a good idea to to get into
fine-tuning deepseek and and doing open
source uh coding agents focused on
autominalization.
But like this recent experience of
several people is that the newer heavier
models are really
uh quite a bit more powerful than the
smaller older models and all all of this
is proprietary. Uh so it could still be
the case that that there is some kind of
phase ph face transition.
Uh that kind of just happened recently
where the kind of amount of general
reasoning the new models are capable of
doing is good enough to to do some of
these things. While for the older
smaller models it it wasn't uh so good.
So yeah, that that's kind of a caveat if
you if you want to go into like this
kind of open source uh hacking of the
open source open source models. It it
might be frustrating. Uh but yeah, I I
have no doubt that in couple of months
or at most a year we will have open-
source fine-tuned models for doing this
and it will cost us $1 instead of $100
to to to do it.
Well, so my impression is that the the
model doesn't have too much trouble with
it. Uh so so then it's kind of really
posing the question how much is this
doing auto formalization and how much it
is doing some some theorem proving but
like the big caveat which I already
mentioned is that this is a book which
has existed for decades and
a lot of students have been taught
topology from from that and I would
expect that basically all the exercises
is have a solution somewhere out on the
internet. So it's it's like um you you
would again need to do these experiments
with some controlled
open-source model or a model that you
trained fully by yourself and you know
what is in the training data and what is
not in the training data. so that you
could have some claims about uh how good
it is in uh basically solving new
problems in these exercises from from
scratch. Uh currently at least I I
didn't really focus on watching it too
much. I I kind of more focused on
preventing it from trying to solve the
exercises. But my my impression was that
it it didn't have much trouble. So
solving the exercises.
Yeah. Thanks for having me.
Uh okay guys. So good luck with auto
formalization. See you sometimes.
Bye-bye.